let's try to come up with the reaction
of when we have this molecule right here
reacting with sodium
sodium methoxide in a methanol solution
or with methanol as the solvent
with methanol as the solvent and just so
we get a little practice of naming let's
see this is one two three four carbons
so it has butte as a prefix no double
bonds or triple bonds so it is butane
and we have a chloro group here so if we
start numbering at the side closest to
it one two so it's two chloro this is
two chloro
two chlorobutane so let's think about
let's think about what might happen here
so the first thing
let me just let me just
redraw the molecule right there the
first thing you need to realize is this
sodium this sodium methoxide it is a
salt it is in when it's not dissolved
it's made up of a positive sodium cation
let me draw them right here a positive
sodium cation
a positive sodium cation and a negative
methoxide anion so let me draw the
methoxide part right here so a negative
methoxide anion
and then it has
so normally we'd have just two pairs but
now we have three pairs here the oxygen
has an extra
electron the oxygen has an extra
electron actually let me draw another
electron as the extra electron this will
be useful for our mechanism
so it could be any of them but the
oxygen has an extra electron has a
negative charge in solid form when
they're not dissolved they form an ionic
bond and they form a crystal-like
structure it's a salt but when you
dissolve it in something in a solution
in this case we have methanol as the
solution they will dissociate from each
other and what you have right here is
this methoxide
right here this is a very very very
strong base
so this right here
this right here is a strong
this is a strong base and if you use the
lewis definition of a base that means it
really really really wants to give away
this nucleus to something i'm sorry this
electron to something else if you use
the bronsted lowry definition this means
that it really really really wants to
take a proton off of something else and
in this situation that is exactly what
it will do and i'll just give you one
i'll actually give you the the the
the most likely reaction to occur here
and we'll talk about other reactions and
why this is the most likely reaction uh
in future videos
so it wants to nab a proton it is a
strong base it wants to give away this
electron
so let's say that it gives away this
electron it gives away to this electron
to this hydrogen right over here now
this hydrogen already had an electron if
it's getting an electron from the
methoxide from the methoxide anion the
methoxide base then it can give away its
electron to the rest of the molecule so
now it can give away this electron to
the rest of the molecule now carbon
won't need the electron carbon doesn't
want to have a negative charge maybe
simultaneously that electron
goes to that carbon
right over there but once again this
carbon doesn't want it it only has four
bonds but what we see is we have this
chloro here this is a highly
electronegative
i guess you could call it a group right
now the chlorine is very electronegative
so the whole time the chlorine was
already tugging on this electron right
here so now all of a sudden this is all
happening simultaneously when an
electron becomes available to this
carbon then now this chlorine this
carbon doesn't need this electron
anymore the chlorine already wanted it
so now the chlorine the chlorine can
take the electron and just like that in
exactly one step let's think about what
happened if all of this this whole chain
reaction and i shouldn't call it a chain
reaction the simultaneous reaction
occurred what are we left with
what are we left with so let me
let me redraw
my
2-chlorobutane
but i'm going to have to change it now
so now the chlorine this has disappeared
so
let me clear it
that's disappeared the chlorine has now
left
it has now left this chlorine is now up
here it is left it had this electron
right over there which is right over
there and then the other the electron it
was paired with that was forming a bond
is now also on the chlorine is now also
on the chlorine so now it becomes a
chloride anion so now it is a chloride
anion if i want to draw the rest of let
me draw the rest of the valence
electrons one two three four five six
and i had the seventh one right here one
two three four five six seven eight now
so it now has a negative charge now this
electron up here let me be now let me
clear let me clear this part out as well
so
let me clear that out as well
now this electron right here this
magenta electron this is now given to
this carbon so let me draw it here so
that magenta electron is now given to
that carbon and if we look at the other
end the one that was paired with those
bond with it still is bonded with it so
that is that green electron is now still
on that carbon and now they are bonded
and now they're forming a double bond so
now they are forming a double bond this
all of a sudden has become an alkene and
now the methoxide took the hydrogen the
methoxide took the hydrogen so let me
redraw the methoxide
so
och3
the oxygen had one two
three four
five it had six oh well actually it had
eight valence elect actually had seven
valence electrons one with the carbon
and then all of these six unpaired ones
neutral oxygen has six but now it gave
one of them away to a hydrogen it gave
that green electron over there to the
hydrogen it grave that green electron
over there to this hydrogen let me do it
i'll do this i'll make this hydrogen in
the same color to this hydrogen
right over here so now this hydrogen is
now bonded with it
this bond hydrogen is now bonded with it
so what are we left with we have a
chloride anion
we have a chloride anion so this is
chloride
chloride anion we now have methanol this
was a strong base now it has become it's
it's conjugate acid so now we have
methanol
methanol which is the same as the
solvent same solution so it kind of just
or actually same as a solvent so it's
now mixed in
and now we're left
off with one two three four still four
still we still have
four
we still have four carbons but now it's
a it's a it's an alkene we have a double
bond so we could call this but ii
en or sometimes called two butene so
let's think about what happened here it
all happened simultaneously both
reactants were present there was
actually only one step so this is the
rate determining step so if we were to
try to name it we'd probably have a 2 in
it someplace and something got
eliminated the chloride the chloride or
i guess you could call it the
the chloro group got eliminated it left
it was a leaving group in this situation
so this
this was eliminated
this was
eliminated
eliminated and this type of reaction
where something is eliminated and
both of the reactants are participating
in the rate determining step and we only
had one step here so that was the rate
determining step is called an e2
reaction e2
it is called an e2 reaction and once
again e stands for elimination
elimination
and the two stands for that both both
reactants involved in the rate
determining step we had one reactant and
two reactants they were both involved in
the rate determining step e2 just like
sn2 i mean it's obviously not the same
reaction but sn2 had substitution with
leaving group left nucleophile came it
was a substitution using a nucleophile
so that's the s and the n and then the
two was we had both reactants it was all
happening simultaneously i'll leave you
there we're going to go into more detail
on the different types of e2 reactions
which ones are favored and then we'll
talk a little bit about e1 and you can
maybe guess what that's going to be
based on our experience with sn2 and sn1